bien commencer squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur the forest si une mise à
jour qui n'est pas des moindres
puisqu'on peut jouer en [ __ ] de côté
ou en opérations mon gars avec des
tétons petit flotte et tout pas faire un
piège à lapin je vais en faire un tout
de suite pourquoi tueries aux audois
survivre [ __ ] bien à jane qui veulent
nous attaquer mais capleers un diadème
ical au oui non et c'est pas croyab 26,7
karim ben y'a les attaques parce tu les
attaques maille haut mais j'étais en
train de casser un truc était passé dans
les attaques
non moi on fait quoi alors bon les
attaques embuscade à temps il en stricte
mais pourquoi les amours des strictes
dans ce jeu c'est bon il est mort et toi
tu attends je vais je vais te regarder
quand même c'est un peu comme il est
mais est-ce que tu as couper un arbre en
même temps comme moi esprits ce qu'on
construit une cabane dans les dents en
haut d'un arbre c'est bon je vais poser
mec mais non mais d'émerger qui sont
trop vite je crois même plus loin si
vous mettez à manger ou pas est-ce que
tu as barguelonne ton estomac il est
plein mais oui il faut des médicaments
toit de la barre de vie à tanger singer
ma barre de vie foule à bata aperçoit
somatiques alors à ce moment-là qu'ils
me regardent et outils ou thé où je vais
te sauver mon amour oui tu j'arrivais
j'arrive moi d'abord parce que notre
amour est éternelle ville portuaire en
courant comme un singe a fait que tu
m'as menti et me regarde couper du bois
comme ça ça m'excite grave mais il a
pris peur totale c'est trop de sueurs
trop de fuir en toi qu'a raconté l'homme
c'est mon arbre arrête va se donner des
coups arrête arrête avec vata c'est mon
pied est faite à coups de hache ensemble
voilà je coupe l'herbe à côté c'est mode
as tu fais quoi je cours plus vite que
toi mais la hausse était de lire j'avais
fait tous les coups ce dernier faut que
je mangeais plus d'énergie permet à
fatick et mérité un perso qui va mourir
en fait et manque plus que qu'un truc
j'arrive mon cas mon mitia pardon au nom
tu vas aller voler tient en trois sets
but surtout gros front on attend peu
moins de temps bah oui peut monter
dedans mais que c'est le but
par contre comment on fait ah non tu
rigole mais [ __ ] c'est de la cote
d'aprr h3c boguey c'est buggé
une seule solution la manifestation
paypal est prêt
barret les cas tu sais content d'arriver
là tu le sais lucas dont c'était la
maison fuite
ouah c'est briguer jusqu'au bout avec
ces noms ont fait un banc et on dort sur
le banc on fait un bon chacun non je
suis construit tiens tu veux ma copine
non mais arrête mais c'est comme ça que
tu prends soin de ta copé le manga c'est
scandaleux coimères ailes d'ange bambino
trois offres pour moi tu relève sont
pour lui tant des coups de hache quoi
dit qu'elle en plein essor doit dire si
toi m'at on attend je m'assois avec anne
on va dire je suis sur toi je viens on
va chercher ce qu'assure le bateau et on
revient à ba voila un petit ben oui un
petit peu pas évident et on a beaucoup
n'y a pas de requins l'aller mais
l'écart a calé en quarts mais kg mais je
vis tu dis n'importe quoi il n'y a pas
de requins cette blague mais pourquoi tu
viens pas avec tes grosses couilles
molles [ __ ] oui c'est quoi là tu vas
être deg parce que tu vas voir ce que
j'ai ramassé tu mets des gangs à je te
regarde regarde ça non ouais les mecs tu
vois vraiment les requins n'y a aucun
avocat quoi bon gars que j'ai ramassé
quoi au wat mais craint qu'un boucher
quoi regarde ce que j'ai ramassé eux
voilà j'ai moi aussi j'ai quand même
ouais ouais mais peut mieux faire non
elle est nue d'un coup tu lui as mais à
quoi elle s'est retrouvée toute nue non
plus tu lui cassent le dos avec ta truc
à j'ai trouvé un stack de trouver de
stack ballast a bien failli j'ai trouvé
disney qui ont fermé ma gueule comme il
y en a tout plein mon cas c'était que
les gros porc c'était prévu c'était le
chrono de gros en fait tout le monde
doit sa valise a mis plein de bars de
tout y est luc amical car bien bataillé
pictet près des prêts ils sont là bas
ils nous regardent regard ils nous
provoquent la neige tassée rouillard
paul etia nos on va c'est surtout un
cocktail maison mais si ténue
ils sont partis mais qui l'on dira cette
version trop nul quand je vois un
terreau de tête et loire est laisse
lardet l'inter de ma tête en deux ans ça
suffit
un gros des pardons à vialas insolent
aux disparitions
regardez voilà au sens de ma tante sors
de ma [ __ ] de tentes
attention je mets un coup de retard de
trois coups de hache
gentil ça enfin tu vois la taille de sa
là ça a donné ça brise est à la
recherche du bâton pour pêcher c'est
parti on y va alors ya des budgets
nationaux dans le bec à l'eau mais qui
revient en bus car tu es prêt tu me suis
tu ne suis pas ils s'en foutent ils vont
courir chez toi tu suivras amis sont
partis chez nous
oui et on va les chasser au muscade
l'aubisque et 80 c'est toi tais toi sur
la plage son appétit will i am à anosy
papa will cadeau je suis là pour te sont
dangereux dans le temps oui où ils
veulent te tapes amicales ou non parce
que je suis là y'en a encore
bâle un pardon il y en a un gars de la
barbie cas il y en a un qui a tout
d'abord mis k -o nayap la barbe tueront
le c'est bon la cia il a fait de sa
passion de cailloux ce petit soleil perd
notre cabane c'est beau hein
c'est une belle série notre cabane 11
ans est le dieu du foot attaque serveurs
fait ici ça il a eu un coup d'argent se
retournant quand même très ce propos par
les sentiments howe est un mec un gros
la pomme a eu pour le parisien elle
provoque pas les oreilles moi quand ils
meurent ils deviennent nu et il leur
manque une partie de leurs cheveux ouais
mais caviar mangent les béquilles à la
bien tu as mangé les baies ponard
c'était du poisson ya une grotte elle
est où la main devant moi ok on y va ce
parti ah oui plus tard une belle grotte
quoi ces partis en bus quand je regarde
show beach romy kg par kraft est un truc
que tu vas être qui fait mon gars bon
non à quoi tu gâches toujours toutes les
surprises comme ça alors est-ce que les
bombes ont été patché parce qu'à chaque
fois je vais utiliser une bombe dans le
jeu ça fait n'importe quoi
hop bouge pas avoir
aa je vais trouver ma femme la femme de
ta vie oui cc by sa princesse mais oui
alors ça d'accord samedi je suis dans
l'eau en fête au dessus de voir saute au
nom adidas tu t'en connais mon dieu
amenam le regarde mais pas tous trois en
fait c'est buggé la grotte est sous
l'eau là oui on va mourir aux nantais où
je ne vois que dans un trou noir
bon voilà à cause du bug de mika on a dû
relancer la partie à [ __ ] de [ __ ] un
homme est mort voilà c'est ça tombe par
terre
hier at-on la peur non ça ce nom les
touche pas les touches mois et touche
pas ils servent à rien ils servent à
rien m'en fous attend avait arrête tu
toucheras temps pc oui je suis sérieux
j'y vais tous vous brouillez [ __ ] je
peux plus courir du baissier l'écart est
avec a pas toucher aux ratons laveurs
non mais qu'à toi c'est quoi c'est une
branche nord il ya une feuille dessus
attend est ce que je peux vous les tuez
faire un pétard made in the way je vais
défoncer des morts a atteint champlain
arbres bah oui bah oui moi je serais tu
m'as vu des coups de bâton arrête
maintenant c'est notre maison c'est ma
maison ma femme et moi je n'étais je
suis en train de pousser tu le vois pas
toi ah merde voilà moi je me suis jetée
entendu de casser les gens je suis mort
au nom mais carrément mais tu en veux
mais c'est une catastrophe cette vidéo
on va faire une expérience humaine mais
cas ok je suis si heureux de te
retrouver et rejoignons nous habitue
travers ce piège c'est ça benoît
l'agencé dia france et des deux sources
de fonds restants quoi bon il ya de
nombreuses très nombreuses améliorations
à faire et c'est pas du tout stable mais
ça fait déjà bien prise de poids joue
avec son ami ben à savoir garder
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça vous a
plu comme d'habitude on se retrouve très
vite dans une nouvelle chute au monde
pis